The Big Bang Theory is one of the most popular
sitcoms of all time, but the show isn't perfect.
Over the course of nearly 300 episodes,
writers sometimes forgot plot points and actors
occasionally lost touch with their characters.
Here are the goofs that are hardest to overlook.
Sheldon Cooper is a creature of
habit. Perhaps because he is a
scientist striving to find meaning
and order in a chaotic universe,
he exerts control over nearly every part of his
life. This manifests in his strict dinner schedule
and his "spot." It's well understood among
his social circle that no one is to sit on
the far right end of the brown couch in the
apartment's living room, except Sheldon.
"Hello, Penny."
"Hello, Sheldon."
"You're in my spot."
He has called that comfortable and familiar
spot a, quote, "single point of consistency"
in a world in flux, upon which he has placed
"eternal dibs," in part because it has a good
angle of the TV and never gets too hot or
too cold. On the prequel show Young Sheldon,
young Sheldon has a similar spot of
preference in his school cafeteria.
Nevertheless, The Big Bang Theory's directors
sometimes forget about this major element of
Sheldon's character, and allow other
people to sit in the hallowed spot,
even while Sheldon is in the room. It's weird
that someone so adamant about his seat on the
couch doesn't notice or mind when Howard or
Leonard occupies it, but hey — that's TV for you.
Sheldon Cooper's strict approach to the
calendar applies to everything from meal
planning to his leisure activities. Early in
the show, it's established that Sheldon and
the guys have a weekly standing date to play
the video game Halo every Wednesday night.
Penny hits Sheldon and Leonard's apartment
during one session and mentions that Christy,
her friend from back home in Nebraska,
showed up uninvited and is staying at
her apartment. Upon hearing that Christy is
promiscuous, Howard flees the game and goes
across the hall to proposition her, and the
two wind up using Penny's bedroom to hook up.
"Well, um, Howard and Christy are
kind of hooking up in my bedroom."
Penny, with nowhere to sleep that night, crashes
on the couch in Sheldon and Leonard's place.
That's all well and good until
the next morning, when a robe-clad
Sheldon is mad that a sleeping Penny has
interrupted his Saturday morning tradition
of watching Doctor Who. Either The Big Bang
Theory writers goofed up and forgot that the
previous evening was Wednesday, or Penny slept
continuously from Halo Night to Saturday morning.
Roommate disputes are voluminous and varied on
The Big Bang Theory, especially between precise
Sheldon and exasperated Leonard. As a preemptive
measure — and to make sure his home life strictly
adheres to his tastes in every way — Sheldon draws
up a lengthy and elaborate "Roommate Agreement."
Its existence is referred to often, as are its
comically numerous articles, riders, and clauses.
One aspect of the agreement, a "girlfriend clause"
is especially ridiculous. Per Sheldon's legalese,
any relevant woman is considered to be
cohabiting with Leonard and Sheldon and
is subject to all the rules and costs of such
if she stays over for 10 straight nights,
more than nine total nights over three weeks, plus
all the weekends of a month, plus three weekdays.
Even though this Roommate Agreement gets
brought up throughout The Big Bang Theory,
Leonard violates the "girlfriend clause"
with regularity and there's little to no
fallout. All of Leonard's female romantic
partners stay over, and stay over often,
including Stephanie, Priya, and
Penny, with little incident.
For the first few seasons of The Big
Bang Theory, Sheldon Cooper loves cats,
but in a strictly theoretical sense, as he's
allergic. Several times, Sheldon insists that
Penny sing his favorite childhood song in order
to soothe and relax him in times of physical or
emotional duress: "Soft Kitty," which is about
how a kitty is soft, warm, covered in fur, happy,
sleepy, and likes to purr. In The Fuzzy Boots
Corollary, the third episode of the entire show,
Leonard considers compensating for the lack of
a romantic relationship in his life by getting
a cat, assuring an extremely worried Sheldon
that the latter's medical sensitivities won't
come in to play, because he's going to buy
a genetically-modified hypoallergenic cat.
"Oh, I hope that scratching post is for you."
But three years later, in the fourth
season episode The Zazzy Substitution,
it's Sheldon who gets a cat to deal with the
loneliness he's enduring after breaking off
his romance with Amy Farrah-Fowler. Worried that
the first cat, named Dr. J. Robert Oppenheimer,
after the famous scientist, is lonely, Sheldon
adopts more cats, all of them named after great
men of science, all except for Zazzles, who is a
decidedly "zazzy" little fellow. Bringing home so
many cats is a sign of an emotional breakdown
for Sheldon, but it doesn't trigger a physical
one — he doesn't exhibit a single symptom
of his previously explained cat allergy.
"Now if you'll excuse me, the father of
the atomic bomb wants a saucer of milk."
While Howard Wolowitz is often mocked by
Sheldon Cooper for not having a PhD — he
holds a mere master's degree in aerospace
engineering from MIT — he achieves something
that no other character on the show does: He
goes to space. In a plot arc spanning seasons
five and six of the show, Howard is selected
to travel to the International Space Station
alongside two other astronauts. Heading to
space has its ups and downs for the goofy
Howard, but it's ultimately a rewarding
experience he appreciates — which is good,
because in real life, someone like him
would likely never make it to the ISS.
In a real-life space training program, he would
have been weeded out and disqualified in any
number of ways, such as when he has trouble
navigating NASA 's flight-preparation system.
"They do it over and over again, no
matter how many times you throw up."
Neither would he pass the physical,
what with his genetic predisposition
to heart problems and severe asthma
both putting him out of the running.
Sitcoms are decidedly unrealistic, and The
Big Bang Theory is no exception. It seems
unlikely that a bunch of thoughtful, intelligent
people with active social lives would hang around
someone as mean, controlling, and judgmental
as Sheldon Cooper for more than a dozen years.
But it's downright illogical that someone
like Penny would live next door to Sheldon
and Leonard in the first place. Seriously,
the entire premise of the show – guy falls
in love with attractive neighbor
— is built on an economic fallacy.
When the show begins in 2007, Sheldon and
Leonard have been roommates for years,
both contributing to the rent on their spacious
Pasadena apartment with the salaries they earn as
doctorate-holding, high-level scientific
researchers at the prestigious California
Institute of Technology. According to Forbes, each
character would be pulling in at least $100,000
a year, more than enough to afford half of
an apartment in expensive Pasadena. And yet
Penny moves into the same building,
right across the hall. Granted,
her digs feature just one bedroom, so it
would cost a little less than the guys' pad,
but it doesn't seem possible that she'd be
able to afford similar accommodations as two
well-compensated scientists on the stingy
salary of a Cheesecake Factory waitress.
Sheldon Cooper isn't like most people. A
super-genius who attended high school as
a little boy and graduated college by the time
he was 14, he's always had a hard time relating
to people his own age. Moreover, he operates
from such a staunchly logical and scientific
mindset that he fails to grasp emotionally-driven
behaviors or subtle nuances in conversations,
particularly sarcasm. When he senses that someone
is being sarcastic, he has to receive confirmation
of it – Leonard even resorts to holding up a sign
that reads "sarcasm" when its use is appropriate.
"What's funny?"
"That wasn't sarcasm?"
Despite Sheldon's complex relationship with
sarcasm, however, he's still a character in a
broad sitcom, and sitcom characters are the most
naturally sarcastic people in all of fiction.
Within that segment, Sheldon Cooper is arguably
one of the most acerbic, sneering, and, yes,
sarcastic individuals to ever grace a TV
screen. He doesn't understand sarcasm,
apparently, but he employs it all the time.
This one is such a glaring discrepancy that
it's really just better to let it go entirely.
"You know how you're always
trying to learn about sarcasm?"
"No."
"No?"
"I was being sarcastic."
While all four male main characters and their
partners on The Big Bang Theory gather most
nights for takeout dinner at the big apartment,
the guys all work together at the California
Institute of Technology, and as such also
get together seemingly every workday for
lunch in the school's cafeteria. This
means there's a lot of eating on the
show – and pretending to consume food on stage
or screen is an acting challenge unto itself.
The performers don't actually eat the various
sandwiches and salads on offer in the CalTech
lunchroom. Instead, the actors just move
their forks and knives around to mimic the
process of dining, without placing the prop
food into their mouths. They're remarkably
bad at pulling this off convincingly,
and once you see it, it's hard to miss.
There exists a small pantheon of
heard-but-not-seen characters from
across TV history, and Howard's mother,
Mrs. Wolowitz, is a prime example. In
what amounts to a running gag, the show strongly
establishes that Mrs. Wolowitz is morbidly obese,
so large, in fact, that no actress
could play her. But every so often,
an episode gives viewers more of Mrs.
Wolowitz than just her screaming at her son
in an exaggerated New Jersey accent — and it
always conflicts with her allegedly huge size.
At one point, she wraps her arms around
Raj, and while they're the only part
of Mrs. Wolowitz on camera, they are
the limbs of an average-sized woman.
"Where ya going?"
When Howard marries Bernadette in a
rooftop ceremony before he goes into space,
the mother of the groom is seen
in an overhead shot of the affair.
Standing off to the side in a pink dress, Mrs.
Wolowitz doesn't seem to be all that heavyset.
Perhaps it's because an occasional but major
role on the most popular sitcom on TV pays well.
Perhaps it's because celebrity stunt casting
is fun for a show's cast, crew, and fans.
Whatever the reason, The Big Bang Theory had
lots of fun casting well-known performers
to play the parents of its regular characters.
The Good Wife and The Good Fight star Christine
Baranski appeared on The Big Bang Theory 16
times as Leonard's mother, Beverly Hofstadter,
a world-renowned psychiatrist and neuroscientist.
The first time she shows up, in the 2009 episode
The Maternal Capacitance, she analyzes Penny
and helps her work through her parental issues.
At one point, Penny tells Beverly about her
childhood, referring to her father as "Bob."
"I mean, my mom could have just said,
'Bob! Get over it. She's a girl. Move on."
A year and a half later, Oscar-winner
Keith Carradine made his first of
five appearances on The Big
Bang Theory as Penny's stern,
protective father. But he introduces
himself not as Bob, but as Wyatt.
"Thanks for the steak, Wyatt."
Penny's father apparently has
two first names? Regardless,
like Penny, his last name is never revealed.
The Big Bang Theory is a show about
scientists, but not so much a show about
science. While it's understood that most of the
main characters work to unlock the secrets of
the universe in some way or another, the show
doesn't bog itself down with anything more than
the occasional mention of a famous scientist.
As a result, The Big Bang Theory rarely shows
the guys doing any real science work. When
they conduct experiments, they're fun things
that make for good television, despite being
completely and woefully scientifically inaccurate.
In The Vengeance Formulation, co-worker
Barry Kripke pranks Sheldon before an NPR
interview by pumping his office
full of helium. The intended effect:
Sheldon's voice goes hilariously high-pitched.
"As I was saying, an ordinary
magnet has two poles."
The real-life effect: Sheldon would have
suffocated to death with so much helium
replacing life-giving oxygen. As for Leonard, one
of his job perks is getting to use a giant laser
for science stuff. A real university's laser
would have numerous safety protocols in place,
such as the device not functioning if
the door to the laser room was open.
And yet when Leonard uses his laser, he carelessly
leaves the door ajar, and he wears no safety
equipment while operating the laser.
Check out one of our newest videos right
here! Plus, even more Looper videos
about your favorite shows are coming
soon. Subscribe to our YouTube channel and
hit the bell so you don't miss a single one.